all right the big political rally of the
weekend was when a soaking dripping wet
Trump showed up to very windy Texas
supposedly to campaign in favor of Texas
governor Greg Abbott and Texas
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick and
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton it was
all about himself it was all about me me
I'm the victim everything bad happens to
me and yeah I guess vote for these
people sort of if you need to or if you
want to uh a very scary rally Trump not
only looked disoriented glitched about a
dozen or 14 times most rallies he he
brain glitches two or three times uh but
glitched at least a dozen times but also
saying things that are so crazy that we
have to wonder if Trump really believes
this stuff something must be going on
where he has entered an alternate
reality one that doesn't exist here He
suggests he's going to sue to get
people's Pulitzer prizes taken away and
then wants Fox hosts to be given
Pulitzer prizes fantasy world he might
as well be on Nars so you have reporters
from The Washington Post the New York
Times they've got Pulitzer prizes and
they bullied the exact wrong thing so
within the next two weeks we're suing
the Pulitzer organization to have those
prizes taken back that's almost
certainly not going to happen and of
course if it does no prizes are being
taken back
we'll be doing that over the next two
weeks I think it's a very good lawsuit
but we'll see but uh we're soon think of
it they got the Pulitzer Prize for wrong
reporting
but other people
should have gotten the Pulitzer Prize
because frankly they got it right for
years
and they don't do like surprises for
guys like Sean Hannity oh but they
should by a different name and Tucker
Carlson and Janine Pirro imagine giving
Janine Pirro a Pulitzer Prize that did
but uh you know most belligerent
monologue
and Laura and so many different people
but they don't get anything they give
police
uh really really scary wacky stuff and
then of course Trump pulled out the c
word no no no not about women guys get
your mind out of the gutter I'm talking
about the word communism for our very
eyes Biden and his left-wing handlers
are turning America into a police state
and I don't even think it's fighting to
be honest with you but they got some bad
people around Now understand that at the
same speech he said Biden and Democrats
don't care about our police they're
defunding police they're getting rid of
police and turning America into a police
state with which police
like something straight out of a
communist country see I used to say
socialists but we've skipped socialism
we don't talk about that I don't even
mention it anymore we're not socialists
anymore we're Communists we've gone over
socialism we're gone it's over it's
Communists they're talking about
Communists it's a communist system now
of course there is absolutely nothing
communistic about Joe Biden whatsoever
uh in fact he's he's almost too much of
a Centrist for the social Democrats to
even like him but all of these terms
meaning less essentially because Trump
and the people behind him don't even
know what they mean Trump then continues
to tell the lie that it was Nancy Pelosi
who failed to use the military on
January 6th he's the commander-in-chief
of the military though we talk about the
fact that Nancy Pelosi refused to use
the military and they didn't need 10 000
to 20 000 if they had 500 people it
would have been more than enough now of
course Donald Trump was the
commander-in-chief of the military at
that time and remember Trump claims he
ordered 10 000 troops and Nancy Pelosi
said no there is no evidence that Nancy
Pelosi said no to anybody not nor that
she has the authority to and there's
also no evidence that Donald Trump
ordered 10 000 troops you know like you
order a Big Mac uh simply no evidence of
that at all at another point during the
rally Trump alluded to a really insane
conspiracy theory that there were
satellites that changed votes from him
to Biden so we've heard about there were
massive dumps we've heard about you know
the number of sandwiches didn't make
sense that they brought for the poll
workers we've heard all these other
conspiracy theories but this is a this
is an extra crazy this paper about it's
the old-fashioned way that's the way
you're going to stop would you agree
with that Mike that's the way you're
going to stop it
it's the only way
we don't need satellites sending the
signals all over the place somebody
votes let's say I'm going to vote for
Trump I love Trump I'm going to vote for
Trump trump being because all over the
world comes back by how did that happen
yeah also it's kind of crazy that if you
see you know some of these conspiracy
you sometimes come across conspiracy
theories that are not based in reality
but they have an internal logic where
like if you accept that the conspiracy
is possible and exists it has an
internal logic this one doesn't even
make sense you're going to in instead of
just flipping the vote on the machine
you're going to send the vote through a
series of geostationary satellites and
then it'll come back as a vote for
someone else like it's overtly it's
overly complicated it doesn't even make
any sense
um Trump then this was maybe the most
depraved moment of the entire thing
Trump said the way to get the
information out of the Russia dossier
uh person
is to put them in court and tell put him
in jail and tell them they'll be raped
in jail and the crowd laughs at prison
rape easily made public you know in this
country they leak all over the place
even on the Supreme Court by the way you
have to find the liquor of the supreme
but you have to find The Leaguer you
know how you find the leaker they'll say
oh this is treasonous what I said so
they can't find the leaker he leaked all
about row v Wade look this person leaked
from the Supreme Court never happened
you know how you find but they don't
want to mention this because I think
it's so terrible you take the writer
because you're never going to find
another going through phone records it's
been a long time you take the writer and
or the publisher of the paper a certain
Paper it you know and you say who is the
leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they said it's okay you're going to jail
and when this person realizes that he is
going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly
[Applause]
he will say I'd very much like to uh
tell you exactly who that leaker it was
built so the joke is our prisons are so
unsafe sometimes people are sexually
assaulted oh that Donald Trump is so
clever uh dystopian moment the a group
of Q Anon type people interrupted Trump
and started singing the National Anthem
at the rally and Trump aloud the entire
thing to go on time he talks she cries
dogs these are the people we have but
remember this January 6 this committee
the two things they didn't talk about
two things was that the people went down
there and you could have had over a
million people
[Applause]
cult
so understand and they sing the entire
thing understand what happened there
okay cult leader Trump
was bemoaning that they are going after
the January 6th rioters and as he does
that in a show of defiance and seemingly
support for the rioters and I guess
they're implying the rioters did
something very patriotic the crowd
stands up led by a sort of conspiracy
group in the front row area based on
reports I've read and start singing the
National Anthem this is a cult anything
the cult leader says must be defended
and if it says if he says something
really crazy you get up and you sing the
national anthem Trump then ranting about
the boxes continuing to make wild claims
this time about presidents putting boxes
in Chinese laundries and I can assure
you this does nothing to exculpate Trump
from what he did with those documents
and look at to me for a long time Dr
Ronnie I'll tell you what they found
nothing they have found
one thing I will say they found that I
like you am a great Patriot
it's a disgrace what's going on
like the boxes hoax have you looked at
the boxes hoax okay this is a new one
the boxes you know Mar-A-Lago have you
seen the last five or six presidents
what they did they took it they're in
Chinese laundries they're stored they're
in storage houses where the windows and
doors are broken it's a disgrace
now we've already looked at each of
those claims individually they're all
either deceptive or outright false but
it doesn't matter they they just grow
while the Q Anon music played then Trump
attacked electric vehicles we are a
nation whose leaders are demanding all
electric cars even demanding though they
can't go far cost too much and whose
batteries are produced in China with
materials only available in China
when an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively in the United
States but not available in China yeah
um there are now this is conservatively
two electric vehicles with a 400 plus
mile range there are
um 15 electric vehicles with a 300 plus
mile range and there are uh almost 20
with a 250 mile range so it's it it it's
it's just pathetic now maybe the
cultiest moment of the rally Trump calls
up Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton to
speak when you go up there if the cult
leader gives you an opportunity to speak
you should damn well better know
that you're supposed to just praise the
cult leader when you're allowed to speak
and that's exactly what Ken Paxton does
hey
so Mr President Dan Patrick and I were
over here asking how does this President
draw a crowd year after year thousands
of people unlike anybody we've ever seen
and and so I've been sitting here trying
to figure it out right
and and the the question I thought was
what did you determine Ken Maybe
a great speaker well Mr President that's
true you're a great speaker but I don't
think that's why everybody's here is it
because he's a great businessman no
clearly is a great businessman but I
don't think that's why everybody's here
maybe it's because you're a great golfer
I don't think that's why everybody's
here
this President and the people that come
to see him are here because in my
opinion you tell me I'm right he's done
more for the American people than any
president in our lifetime
hey
so he was certainly on message he knew
exactly what he was supposed to do scary
cult rally these are serious cultists
serious interventions would be necessary
to get them out and if you need more
proof of that let's look at some of the
interviews with the cult members
I want to tell you about something I use
every day because it simplifies my life
I don't have hours to mathematically
plan every meal or take multiple
different supplements and vitamins to
make sure I'm getting exactly what I
want to get every single day and the
solution is our sponsor athletic greens
product ag1 I've been taking ag-1 for
over a year it's just great it's just
one small scoop of ag-1 in the morning I
get 75 vitamins minerals probiotic all
from whole food sources it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's no
extraneous stuff making wild claims I
drink it straight with water because I
like the taste you can put it in a
smoothie or juice or a shake it's just
simple ag1 is a sustainable routine
because it's just one scoop in the
morning takes one minute once a day I
know I'm covered in getting what I want
I can really be sure that I am properly
nourishing my body with the things I'm
trying to get that's the most important
part athletic greens knows I'm a vitamin
D guy I've talked about in the winter I
take vitamin D to make up for the lack
of sun exposure I take that every day as
well I've mentioned it on the show and
so athletic greens is giving you a free
year of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase when you
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below